dans quelques semaines clamecy aura un
nouveau maire avec la décision de
claudine boisorieux de ne pas se
représenter
la succession est ouverte et nicolas
bourdoune se présente comme l'héritier
naturel adjoint depuis 12 ans dans la
majorité
il veut s'appuyer sur cette expérience
tous les classiques comme connaissent
depuis très longtemps
ils connaissent mon investissement lama
proxy et la proximité que j'ai avec
l'ensemble des habitants nous inscrivons
dans une forme de continuité mais dans
le même temps
nous envisageons de faire de la
politique autrement
une sensibilité de gauche mais la liste
se veut ouverte
les divisions entre ps et dissidents ont
marqué les deux précédents mandats
cette fois pas de soutiens politiques
officielles et une volonté d'apaisement
totalement non partisane où nous sommes
inféodés à aucun parti
l'idée c'est d'en finir avec nos
querelles avec les querelles
les querelles historiques et locales
nous voulons réconcilier les clamecycois
et réconcilier aussi les élus de
l'ensemble du territoire
en face odile maillard joue la carte de
la nouveauté première candidature
première expérience politique
elle entend tourner une page après les
12 années passées par claudine
boisorieux à la tête de la ville une
ouverture de la communication c'est tout
ce que clame ci a besoin pour se
reconstruire
clamecy ville qui bouge c'est clamecy
une ville attractive clamecy
sereine avec une ouverture vers
l'extérieur
voilà ce que je veux porto qui une union
affichée derrière un nouveau visage et
une stratégie de recentrage mais avec
également des figures bien connues des
affrontements fratricides et 15
dernières années
michel car voyeur qui avait porté la
liste socialiste officielle en 2014 et
dominique méchain acteurs de la
quadrangulaire de 2008
notre liste pour moi c'est la liste du
milieu que c'est la voie du centre c'est
là c'est celle qui est différente de
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
donc c'est un besoin que les habitants
nous ont fait partager pour accompagner
les deux liste sans étiquette
une autre affiche clairement la couleur
le rassemblement national
une première dans le nord de la nièvre
mais une candidature logique pour julien
guibert sur un territoire où le
sentiment de déclin résonne avec les
thèmes portés par le parti d'extrême
droite
je pense sincèrement que les les
habitants de clamecy ont envie de
tourner la page 2 de cette gauche cette
commune a toujours été à gauche on voit
très clairement les résultats la
paupière la population de la commune est
passée de 5500 habitants à 3700 nous
avons une perte d'emploi nous avons une
perte de population une perte de service
public il pertes sociales au niveau de
la commune et je pense que les gens
veulent un nouvel espoir dans cette
commune et les ambitions de julien
guibert sont élevées ici le
rassemblement national était arrivé en
tête des dernières élections européennes
et sur cette terre de gauche marine le
pen avait recueilli 35 % des suffrages
au second tour de la présidentielle 2017
35% sa part être suffisante et angulaire
pour gagner donc effectivement je pense
que nous avons aujourd'hui quelque chose
à espérer à clamecy
après deux élections départager à 3 puis
une voix le scrutin s'annonce cette fois
encore indécis à clamecy avec la
possibilité de voir basculer un bastion
historique de la gauche